welcome to the show I'm joining you from
Las Vegas Nevada where it is warm but
the least warm it's ever been when I've
been here I'm here for the mass torts
made perfect conference organized by a
friend of the show Mike Papantonio --hz
law firm that the conference doesn't
actually start until later today so I'll
probably have stories from the
conference tomorrow Sam cedar is here
from the majority report I saw him last
night saw some other of our media
friends including Ferran Cousins host of
Ring of Fire who filled in for me last
week so a lot going on here sort of
meeting of the progressive media minds
of sorts but I'll talk to you more about
that maybe a little bit on the bonus
show today and probably tomorrow Ben
Dixon filled in for me yesterday did a
great job I was able to check out a
bunch of the of yesterday's show and
thanks to Ben and there's one story I
want to start with just just to sort of
get it out of the way which I know Ben
did yesterday and I have such strong
feelings about it that I want to give
you my take on it and this relates to
this very interesting profile of Vice
President Mike Pence that was done in
The New Yorker now of course our sort of
standard understanding of Pence is he is
a true religious right Christian
evangelical ideologue to the point where
he even has some kind of really strange
habits I guess related to his religion
he can't be alone with women other than
his wife or something along those lines
and he at one point wanted to require
cremation services for miscarried
fetuses and just it really goes very far
with Mike Pence but the profile of Mike
Pence in The New Yorker was fascinating
to me not because of what it did say
only but also of what we sort of learned
by reading between the lines about
Donald Trump and it sheds light on to
this idea of has Trump actually become
religious over the last three years by
coincidence when he decided to be
candidate for president of the United
States or is he the guy whose only
philosophy is as I've said greed and
self enrichment and self aggrandizement
and is he just pandering to the
religious right and the article in The
New Yorker about Mike Pence confirmed
beyond any doubt that Donald Trump's
religiosity
is utter and total pandering because he
ridicules the vice-president regularly
for his religiosity before we even get
into the details is it even really
believable that a Venn 68 or 69 year old
man would all of a sudden become
religious become anti-abortion after a
life of being pro-choice become I don't
know cautious about gay rights or really
change his mind on any social issue
I don't think so 68 69 year olds rarely
have these awakenings on these issues so
Donald Trump's religiosity was suspect
to begin with and in The New Yorker
piece about Mike Pence there's a bunch
of examples of Donald Trump just making
fun of Mike Pence and what actually
seems like I I don't feel bad for pence
I think he's an absolutely horrible
person an incredibly dangerous ideologue
but it seems like Trump really for no
reason just ridicules Mike Pence's
really religion so I'll give you three
examples from this New Yorker piece
number one a longtime associate of both
Donald Trump and Mike Pence was quoted
as saying when people stop by Mike
Pence's office at the White House and
then go visit Trump Trump will say sort
of jokingly demeaning Lee did Mike make
you pray did Mike make you pray okay not
a huge deal by itself but a little bit
odd right because Trump is supposedly
religious supposedly the same religion
as Mike Pence and most religious people
wouldn't demean another religious person
by saying did he make you pray when you
visited his office okay number two roe v
wade there was a discussion which is
actually a really logical discussion to
have in the White House with Mike Pence
and Donald Trump and legal advisors
about whether they want to have a
Supreme Court justice that would if
given the opportunity
reverse roe v-- wade roe v wade is the
federal law around abortion and it is
often this sort of litmus test when
Republicans are thinking of bringing in
a new Supreme Court justice they want to
know if given the opportunity would you
reverse rote would you vote to reverse
roe v wade and
usually during confirmation hearings the
Supreme Court nominee won't answer it
they'll say you know I can't prejudge
anything that might come before the
court whatever we know they're
boilerplate answer but a legal adviser
said something pretty astute and obvious
to Mike Pence and Donald Trump which was
you know even if we had a Supreme Court
that reversed roe v wade you would
probably see many states passed
state-level laws to legalize abortion
services and Donald Trump turned to Mike
Pence when they were told that and said
you see you've wasted all this time and
energy on it and it's not going to end
abortion anyway if you're really
anti-abortion the way Donald Trump has
claimed to be during this political
Renaissance or being born-again or
whatever it is that he's had why would
he turn to Pence and say you've wasted
all your truant your time talking about
repealing roe v wade it doesn't make
sense if if Donald Trump also wants roe
v wade repealed and then during that
same meeting we're getting through
example number three now the topic
shifted from abortion to gay rights and
of course Donald Trump for the most part
has been for gay rights throughout his
life although when he became Republican
political candidate Trump he started
issuing all sorts of contradictory
statements on it and Trump pointed to
pence during the meeting and said don't
ask that guy he wants to hang them all
now my initial reaction was how insane
is it that the top elected official in
the country the President of the United
States jokes about something as
important as gay rights in this sort of
flippant and unconcerned way but then I
got to layer two of my reaction which
was Donald Trump has completely utterly
and totally bamboozled his followers and
I've been using the word bamboozled to
refer to the relationship between Donald
Trump and his followers for a long time
the alt-right rallies the Confederate
gatherings all the nonsense of Trump
supporters seeing Trump as this godly
man they've been tricked Donald Trump
could not care less about religion or
abortion or gay rights he has tricked
you and he is literally laughing all the
way to the bank right because his
philosophy is funnel millions of dollars
into his businesses greed self
enrichment self aggrandizement you
thought he was this godly religious man
he's just a vulture who tricked you and
is now benefiting while doing nothing
for you and realistically doing bet
things that are bad for you right taking
away your health care depending on who
you are where you voted in your economic
status tax cuts for the rich not for you
but layer three of the analysis is this
Donald Trump will not hesitate to sweep
the rug out from women or LGBT
individuals or whoever so you meant
hearing me say listen Trump clearly is
not actually anti-abortion he's not
actually anti-gay that may be true but
if Trump for a second thinks that by
passing anti choice or anti-gay
legislation there would be political
gains to be had he won't hesitate to do
it because his philosophy is merely one
of greed and of propping himself up so
although he clearly is not religious
this is not praise of Donald Trump in
any way it's actually furthering the
criticism that his number-one priority
is just to do what he thinks is best for
his political career at the time the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership